Okay.
I want to have an adult conversation with
you about whether strategically it is time
for Bernie Sanders to start attacking Elizabeth
Warren hard if he wants to maintain a shot
at securing the democratic nomination.
Now stop it.
Delete that email draft you've already opened
to me where you're about to rip me a new one.
I want to be really clear here.
This is a strategic conversation.
I'm against toxic democratic infighting.
I believe that we need to be running good
issue-based campaigns, but it is now been
brought up to me several times and I want
to address it on the fact to answer the question,
what can Bernie do to get back in this race?
We just looked at polling data.
The polling data is not looking good for Bernie,
particularly over the last couple of weeks.
Elizabeth Warren has taken a lead in an average
of recent polls and is trending.
She is now nationally the front runner or
you could take co front runner with Joe Biden.
Bernie Sanders had a heart procedure.
He's been off the trail for a little bit.
He's getting back to it, but it has hurt his
poll numbers.
I wish it were different, but this is the
reality that we're dealing with and so I started
seeing messages like for example on our subreddit
where user Wes' NAZ posted about this, who
said from start to present, the Sanders campaign
hasn't gone after Warren.
I think this has been a smart move.
Allowing them to be harder on more conservative
candidates.
However, it is my belief that the time is
now for Sanders to go on the offense.
Here is my case.
Only three candidates remain in double digit
polling.
No one else has a chance.
Number two, Bernie just had heart surgery.
He needs to retake control of the race.
Number three, Bernie's polling has been leveling
off.
He needs to take out Warren and get her supporters.
Number four, he raised more than anyone else
in the third quarter of the year.
He has a strong following and number five,
Warren has been given way too much easy air
time, and she isn't left enough.
She won't make the changes that Bernie will.
I think Warren's presence has been a benefit
for the country, but now she needs to go.
So here's what you have to understand.
This is a strategic analysis.
Imagine that Bernie doesn't go after Warren,
right?
Say Bernie doesn't take the advice from Wes'
NAS and says, I'm not going to attack Warren.
That's not been my strategy.
I'm not going to do it.
He goes into his next debate and he attacks
Joe Biden who he is very different from the
problem is that any damage Bernie is able
to do to Joe Biden helps Elizabeth Warren
as much as it helps him.
Why do I say that?
Because mathematically that's the reality.
If you look at second choices for Biden voters,
30% of Biden voters would switch to Warren.
If they abandoned Joe Biden and 25% of Biden
voters would switch to Bernie.
What this means is that when Biden loses support,
when a Biden supporter sees Bernie destroy
Biden on the stage, they are marginally more
likely to switch their vote from Biden to
Warren than from Biden to Bernie.
Mathematically, that means that going after
Biden is not particularly useful to Bernie
Sanders by successfully attacking Biden, by
making them look really bad.
Bernie is helping Warren at least as much
as he helps himself.
This is a mathematical reality, so this is
an important question.
Is there a path to the nomination for Bernie
to get from the 1415 he's pulling on average
right now to get into the lead?
That does not require taking support from
Elizabeth Warren in the most primitive mathematical
sense.
Yes, all of the other candidates, if you take
out from the a hundred percent right now,
you take out Biden's support and Warren support
and Bernie support.
Everybody else, like Buddha, judge or Rorick,
everybody, they have a total of 22% support.
There's little slices.
Buddha judge has 5.6 Andrew Yang is 2.8 Chelsea
Gabbert has 0.8 all together.
That's 22% but Bernie can't get that full
22% right.
Even if he obliterates every other candidate
and makes everybody say, I need to abandon
all of these people.
Bernie is only the preferred second option
for a slice of those candidates.
So imagine that Bernie so brutally destroys
and embarrass as booted judge, that every
booted judge supporter says, I'm going to
my second choice.
Buddha judge supporters prefer Warren over
Bernie.
Same thing with Carla Harris.
Harris supporters prefer Warren over Bernie.
So I hate this.
I looked at this every which way last night
and this morning.
But mathematically, I don't see a way for
Bernie to win without taking support directly
from Elizabeth Warren, which is tough because
Elizabeth Warren supporters marginally prefer
Biden over Bernie.
Okay?
I don't want to see it.
I don't want to see this get ugly.
There may be intangible collateral damage
that are really ugly showdown between Bernie
and Warren could due to the eventual candidate,
but I know that there are people in my audience
who do want to see it and believe that any
cost to get Bernie the nomination over Warren
is worth it.
Now, of course, that's not even this simple
because there's also the issue of whether
the people who would vote for Bernie would
be convinced to do it by seeing him attack
Elizabeth Warren, that may actually turn voters
off and it's not been Bernie strategy.
It could be anathema to the way that he has
run his campaign.
So my question to you today is, we're being
adults here.
I'm not suggesting anyone do anything.
I'm just telling you what the math says.
Reply in the comments.
If you're watching on YouTube or send me a
tweet at D Pacman.
Is there a way for Bernie Sanders to get back
in control here without going directly after
Elizabeth Warren?
Okay.
If you're listening, let me know on Twitter
at D Pacman, let me know down in the comments
and I will remind you this weekend we have
a major, major membership drive.
We have not done this for about a year.
We are going to be doing a one day massive
membership discount.
If you've been thinking about becoming a supporter
of the David Pakman show, get on our mailing
list@davidpakman.com sign up for it this weekend
you will get an email.
It'll be called something like the email you've
been waiting for.
It will have a code that will work just on
one day.
Maybe it'll work both weekend days just cause
maybe people need an extra day, but it'll
be a weekend only special, the biggest discount
of the year.
I would love to have your support to be notified
of it.
Just get on our mailing list.